if you were forced to battle terrifying
bloodthirsty Killers what would you do
you've been placed on an island full of
vampires and flesh-eating monsters and
it's only a matter of time until you get
killed I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat Blood of ore this kid is going
to watch his entire mutant race die the
world is sick from a virus and the Cure
has caused half of the population to
turn into flesh-eating vampires except
this kid me Liu here he was born from a
vampire dad and a human mother he's a
miracle and the first of his kind
staking up this area with his vampire
friends they spot one of their kind
across the street this hobo is starving
for blood and attacks this woman his
collar lights up red and he screams in
pain and just the inhuman police show up
and brutally kill him me Leo and his
friend are impressed with the police's
reaction time their other friend then
passes by them and Whispers that she's
nervous but Emilio tells her that they
can't wait because it's time to rob a
bank boss testing and nearby they raid
this bank and make all these people
hostages the bank manager tells them
there's no money in the cashier and he
doesn't even have the code to the Vault
but mainly who isn't worried and uses
his sweet hacking skills to easily open
the vault door they quickly Raid inside
but to me Liu is more interested in
stealing these documents meanwhile the
bank manager notices the collar on their
necks and tells them that he feels sorry
for their vampire kind but the man win
Chow here is a hothead and knocks the
bank manager's face in the group then
finishes up and prepares to escape the
bank but when chow gets greedy and tells
them that they should take more money
but Emilio tells them they don't have
time on the way out they drop some cash
and win Chow takes off his mask to pick
it back up but that's when he locks eyes
with this kid he's just seen his face
when chow apologizes to this kid for
what he's about to do and looks dead
into his sweet kind eyes and prepares to
shoot this kid straight in the face okay
well what do you know these kids did the
typical thing going in guns blazing
literally there was a global virus years
ago that made people develop insane
insomnia and when the World created a
cure all these people somehow turned
into vampires because of this cure some
even developed crazy vampire powers
known as hemomancers but these vampires
are dumb as hell and they did this Heist
all wrong and they fit into one of two
type of bank robbers the two categories
are professional and opportunistic while
the first category is as it sounds the
second one is more common among bank
robbers today most Bank heists are
usually committed by desperate untrained
people who a lot of the time aren't even
in it for just the money but for other
reasons as well drugs philanthropy
personal reasons and so on and I'm sure
me Liu's crew would love to think that
they're in the first category how they
act it tells me they really fit into the
second category we can't tell how this
vampire crew entered the bank but it's
more likely that due to the large layout
of this place there's no possible way
that these kids could have rounded up
all of these hostages without alerting
to police bank tellers at the front
usually aren't the only people in the
bank and most banks will also have other
rooms in the building for office and
managerial purposes which will also be
restricted to employees for obvious
reasons this is why it's unlikely that
these kids would have been able to round
everyone up without a rising suspicion
as their crew would have had to travel
deep within this massive building into
restrictive areas to get everyone which
would have left many chances for the
employees here to pull the alarm before
me Leo's crew could have reached them if
I was him I would have personally picked
a local bag to Rob as these are designed
to offer a more personalized customer
experience which means they're usually
smaller in size and potentially in their
security as well many smaller Banks
nowadays are also insured by the
government which means they also won't
hesitate to hand over their cash quickly
and the reduced total square footage
unless employees of the smaller Bank
means that the overall Heist would have
been much quicker Emilio and his best
friend anji stop Wing Chao from
murdering the kit but then her color
suddenly activates she's been marked for
dead meanwhile Chen Fong the getaway
driver enters the bank and tells
everyone that the cops are coming Sirens
starts lightly echoing in the distance
and gets louder and louder about to get
into the car when Chow points his gun at
once you and tells everyone that she
cannot get in and escape with them her
collar was just activated and that means
her location has now gone live and the
cops will soon Trace her Angie tells me
Liu that he's right and prepares to get
gone but melee who thinks fast and comes
up with a backup plan throwing a bag of
cash far onto the street causing wind
Chow to try and get it well Mele you and
anji Escape in the car without him and
Chen Fong and win Chao even discovers
that there's no money in the bag only
documents in the car milieu tells anji
that he made a promise in the orphanage
to be with her forever and that's why he
can't never leave her behind but then
they suddenly get caught and screwed
over real quick later meleo and his crew
get interrogated by the police and as
much as he'd like to think he's safe
because his dad is a big shot police
general dude he has no idea that this
connection will cost him his life Emilio
tells Mr detective here that since they
were caught with no money and because
they are underage they'll just get a
slap on the wrist and soon be free Mr
detective asks if he's confessing to the
crimes and me Liu here says sure sealing
his fate he gets dragged across the
table and Mr detective asks him how can
he be such a cold-blooded killer me Liu
is confused but that's when he notices
pictures of all the hostages at the bank
they've all been murdered even that tiny
little adorable little kid in the
bathroom and the police think that me
Leo and his friends did it the next day
the trial of the bank heist begins and
the country goes wild the public wants
meleu and his friends dead and he begins
to wonder who could have done the
murders since almost all of his friends
were accounted for and the victims had
no bullet holes in their body when they
died wanting to make an example out of
the vampire species this human judge
sentences milieu and his friends to
death later he is heading to his holding
cell when he comes across his daddy the
director of the BTS Emilio still blames
him for not searching for his mom all
those years ago and tells him to piss
off but his dad grabs his wrist and
somehow begins to burn the Flesh on his
skin milieu yells in agony and his daddy
tells him that they're not family
anymore and he passes out shocked awake
meliu realizes that he's now in a small
room full of strangers he has no idea
how he got here or what just happened
before this not realizing that he's
about to enter a vampire death game he
finds a backpack of the floor full of
clothes and a gun he tries to search
this bag belonging to this ponytail Guy
Lee shin and he gets choked by him this
girl next to him wakes up confused and
wonders why is she still alive which is
a rather strange thing to say Shin then
reveals what they're all thinking they
were all sentenced to death but somehow
they've ended up in this box milio that
remembers that his friends were being
transported in a white van when they got
stopped and killed by some men with guns
but he doesn't have any blood on him and
now suspects that his friends might
still be alive they all introduce
themselves and lead to Deuces that sense
there are weapons in their bag the
fighting will start soon just then
Sirens begin blaring as their door
finally opens up and they see dozens
more boxes like theirs hundreds of
bloodivore prisoners step out okay I
would be super terrified right now
because these guys were sentenced to
death and now they're in this strange
Warehouse with guns being given to them
their prisoners what sort of jail is
this the answer folks to say no jail
it's clear from what happened at the
bank that someone sent everyone here up
and they went through Great Lengths to
put them in here and this makes me think
that everything might not be as it seems
if I was merely who I would be even more
worried than he looks right now because
everyone here has now just become
victims of a rather extraordinary
extradition this is when a country has
full authorization to kidnap someone and
purposely circumvent the source
country's laws on interrogation
detention and extradition an operation
of this game scale using only prisoners
means that my government isn't on it
probably one way or another and that
also means that our country of Japan has
likely made it legal to do whatever it
wants to us without any consequences at
this point we don't know what's going on
but there are strength in numbers and we
woke up with a bag of weapons until we
get back with our friends if they're
still alive I would join forces with the
people that we first talked to soon
everyone here will be fighting to be in
control so what I would do is first wait
out to all the excitement ends before
identifying the first person placed in
charge to be leader once identified I
would work with the Lee Shin guy since
he seemed like a Bonafide killer and I
would plan carefully where and when I
would kill him but particularly I would
do it in front of everyone and in doing
so displaying my authority and power
over everyone here and intimidate them
into obeying me I don't have to make
friends I just need to kill this man
quickly and violently and show them that
I am not someone to be crossed because
remember we don't know where we are and
we are stuck with a bunch of killers
meanwhile Mr detective from earlier exam
this white band that his team found and
he thinks it is connected to a new
Mystery Case dozens of prisoners have
begun to die in horrible accidents
accidents so bad that the police haven't
been able to perform any autopsies they
don't know the identities of anyone in
these accidents and no blood has ever
been found frustrated he calls his
Precinct and asks if they can look into
the list of prisoners who have been
killed or gone missing in the last two
years he thinks something else might be
going on back in this Warehouse
prisoners began exiting their cages and
a loudspeaker then welcomes everyone
here to the island of aori this lady
enters the room and me Liu realizes it's
Angie she tells everyone that this is a
special prison for blood divorce here
they will not be sentenced to death
miliu is about to walk up to her when
the real anji pops up behind him she
tells him that she doesn't know what's
going on but they should listen to what
the fake anji has to say first and
that's when feiganji reveals the worst
news of all and tells everyone that they
now must live out the rest of their
lives on the Island and oh by the way
they can never escape this prisoner gets
angry and tries to have some fun with
fake Angie but out of nowhere Chen Fong
saves her and gives her his shirt he
wrestles with this prisoner with me Liu
notices both of their collars light up
he tries to tell them to stop fighting
or else they'll die but other prisoners
start to notice all the girls in the
room the real anji and this brunette
Baddie whose name is Cho gets rather
nervous but that's when wind Chow shows
up again from out of nowhere and saves
me Liu he asks him what went wrong at
the bank and what the hell is going on
now meanwhile Chen Fong gets his ass
kicked by this prisoner dude and that's
when his bloodivore caller starts
counting down and it reaches zero and
his head blows up fake anji then
announces that the prisoners are
forbidden from killing each other and
wearing these collars is the only
restriction in aori everyone can live on
this island as long as they want if they
can survive a terrifying monster
suddenly attacks fake hanji and everyone
begins to panic milieu grabs the real
Angie to retreat and his gang follows
hordes of smaller flesh-eating monsters
start showing up from above and from the
other side and jump right past milieu to
get to the people behind him oh
just hit the fan folks and we need to
think quick if I was him I would take
note that these monsters just now didn't
focus on us but chose to go after the
groups of prisoners in the distance this
sort of animal tactic is known as
Pursuit predation which is basically how
Predators actively choose their prey and
the fact that they chose to not go after
us but the shields of meat behind us
this tells me that these animals
basically assessed that their prey was
more worth it for them than we were fun
fact did you know some predators also
choose to either exhaust their metabolic
prey rapidly like a cheetah or to Pace
themselves during a Chase such as lions
and how the monsters above us were
clearly stalking us before they attacked
tells me that their hunting methods were
more similar to that of a cheetah this
could mean that they have limited energy
to spend on chasing prey since they took
longer to assess us before attacking and
also their proportionally long limbs
confirms to me that they are better
suited to pursuing their prey with speed
rather than stealth using this knowledge
I would work on Gathering only a few
active Fighters that we come across and
would obviously use the large Shield of
meat behind us to buy time while we work
towards climbing towards the top of the
warehouse we already have weapons and
heading towards these windows at the top
will be our fastest way to escape me and
Liu and the real anji continue running
and link up with brunette batty Cho but
that's when this monster surprises them
and prepares to eat milieu right here
and now but that's when his powers
activate and he flies back anji stares
in shock meanwhile though Lee the
distance sees this and realizes that me
Liu is not just a bloody war but a
hemomancer Elsewhere One of the
prisoners manages to make a bomb and
blow up a part of the warehouse and
everyone begins escaping through this
hole but quickly realized that oops it's
a dead end and now they're trapped some
Hebrew monsters in the group think fast
and use their powers to seal this hole
lock them off from the monsters on the
other side of the building though me Liu
finally figures out his powers and uses
them to save Angie and brunette batty
Cho taking them up into this shaft above
he begins to suspect that some of the
prisoners being hemomancers must be part
of the reason why they are here for some
type of experiment but doesn't know why
their robot guide earlier was made to
look like anji crawling through these
vents they find a way out into this
Dusty classroom but something isn't
right they crawled for about two minutes
but somehow they've made it into an
entirely new building he also notices
that this room looks like it hasn't been
used in years but finds out from these
construction plans that this building
isn't supposed to be finished for
another two years he then realizes that
he used to go to school here as a kid
and unlocks an old memory from the past
remembering that when he was little a
bloodyvore entered this school to try
and kill him and his entire school and
even his daddy abandoned him the bad guy
threw him off the building roof and
that's when his power is activated for
the very first time this unlocked memory
shocks made Liu and all of a sudden his
arms begin to light up with a signal but
he doesn't think much of it his group
then leaves this room and explores the
rest of the building to look for weapons
tools and food but see from the window
that in the span of two minutes climbing
up in the shaft they've reached the
fourth floor of this building and it
makes no sense and meleu starts to think
that they've been caught at an
intersection through space-time but
anyways brunette Cho just laughs at him
but then they hear a rumbling alien
sound down this hallway he notices signs
that a firefight took place here scare
the girls ask if he can use his powers
to jump down from here and he says that
there are limitations to his powers he
can create an artificial gravity and
direct himself to it as long as it's in
his line of sight but if he carries too
much or is too heavy for example it
could be like falling from a building
hearing more terrifying noises
approaching him he tells the girls to
stay close to him and he it's ready for
what's to come okay we need to address
some things because as we all know anime
is known for having a lot of what the
bleep moments and this one is probably
going to be the biggest what the bleep
moment of all it doesn't make sense how
these kids automatically assume that oh
hey guys we're in a pocket space
Dimension and that's just the most
logical thing to come up with what
they're suggesting is that this is
basically a small self-contained
universe that exists within another
Universe well it may not make any sense
at all if he's right this could mean
that this might be the way out if I was
meal you I would have taken this more
seriously because a pocket Dimension
usually has its own laws and physics and
can in theory be accessed through a
portal or doorway and if this is true
this means that we could figure out how
to escape by finding this doorway and
this would explain how we managed to
crawl only a few minutes in that shaft
yet somehow arrived on the fourth floor
of that school building earlier suddenly
more and more flesh-eating monsters show
up and me Leo quickly activates his
powers to save them momentarily but more
show up behind and the two girls run
back opening up this door but Cho then
pushes anji towards the monsters and
closes the door behind her the monster
slices Angie's skin and she collapses
helpless me Liu sees this and quickly
comes to her rescue he stabs this
monster and uses his powers to charge it
into this pole he rushes to Angie's
eight but he hears more monsters closing
in meanwhile though back to brunette Joe
she tries to escape but runs into a dead
end so she heads back to her uh friends
like nothing ever happened calling out
to Angie and me Liu and she sticks out
her hand to have them help her but me
Liu ignores her and flies right past her
leaving her to her fate this other Beast
still chases after them so he uses his
powers to stab it with this pole and him
and anji Crush down this hallway and
both of them pass out meanwhile back
inside of the warehouse the rest of the
prisoners have come together to block
these doors and it's not going to be
long before the monsters get in but
that's when this prisoner finally wakes
up and he kills kills all the monsters
here with ease this red eye guy Liu Yao
he's an s-rank war criminal and one of
the most powerful hemomancers alive
after the monster bloodbath Lee suddenly
shows up and tries to attack Lu Yao but
he's too quick Lu Yao then notices that
his collar has lit up but this prisoner
tells him not to worry since his
collar's counter is not at zero and
means it won't explode he then does
something rather crazy and he kills this
prisoner and the counter on his collar
suddenly goes up shocking everyone here
and everyone begins to figure out the
true rules of this game by killing
anything in this world it will add more
time to their collars and prevent them
from blowing up and people begin to
realize that red eye Lou might be the
one to save them nearby Chen Fong tells
Wen Chao that they need to look for me
Liu and hanji but when Chao thinks
they've ditched everybody and gives up
on them suddenly a loud explosion is
heard and LU Yao blasts open these doors
and frees all the prisoners everybody
joins his and they go to try to discover
why they are really here and even when
Chao joins them Chen Fong tries to
convince him to stay with him but when
Chao tells him that it's me Leo's fault
that they were even here left behind
Chen Fong's spot Lee and finds out from
him that he woke up here with me Liu and
Angie he tells changfong that he saw
them Escape earlier in the air shaft
above them and reveals that merely you
is a hemomancer shocking Chen Fong then
the monsters around them start
disappearing and they spot a red crystal
inside of these bodies and it's a red
Crystal that will change everything they
both inspect the red Crystal and touch
it with their hands and they had no idea
that they just triggered the next stage
of their evolution the crystal soon
disappears and to Lee chin agrees to
help Chen find his friends out of the
goodness of his heart but we all know
that he has other intentions and they
begin to track milieu down elsewhere
milio finally wakes up and discovers
that anji is alive but her pulse is weak
getting creative he uses this bullet and
some spark to heal up her wound and just
then a monster nearby also wakes up but
then it crumbles and disappears he tries
to break out of this room and just then
his Crystal hand starts glowing again
playing with it he discovers that it's
actually a super computer named Sapphire
using it he quickly figures out how to
save Angie using a blood transfusion and
discovers more info about his blood of
our kind and this island he discovers
that this place is where the insomnia
cure was developed the Cure that created
the vampire mutants this island was
later used to do experiments onto me Liu
and others of his kind thinking quickly
he uses this supercomputer to find out
more info about the other prisoners here
but finds that that information is even
more classified while I love how me Leo
is casually browsing through this super
computer while his friendly is bleeding
out that's cold as hell I love it but
that's pretty messed up the fact is is
that we've just discovered a super
computer in our wrist that can basically
do anything and unlike what the people
of Reddit think about this show so if I
meal you right now I don't have time to
get hated on by some keyboard Warriors
because at this point all the clues
point back to our daddy and that he is
the head of this weird corporation that
clearly has been experimenting on us
since birth and when you think about the
fact that we're the only half vampire
half human out there it kind of makes
sense it's noted that Daddy burned our
arm in that jail in the very beginning
which if you think about it could mean
that he put this super computer in us
maybe he did it out of the goodness of
his heart probably not though but I
won't deny it is giving us a obvious
advantage in this death game so instead
of just playing around with my
supercomputer I would actually heal anji
first and have her help us in figuring
out the ins and outs of this computer
because two heads are better than one me
Liu here hasn't realized that he just
might be the chosen one in this anime
because everything here seems to be
catered to him it's not a coincidence
that he studied here as a kid or that
his daddy has everything to do with this
place he closes the computer and goes to
donate Angie some of his blood but this
activates her vampire powers and she
wakes up up and bite me Liu and both of
them pass out merely you then dreams of
his missing mother watching her hold his
face she tells him that she'll protect
him until he gets stronger and that's
when he wakes up and discovers that
someone has made a hole through this
wall and now they can finally Escape he
briefly explores the nearby area and
then picks up Angie telling her that he
spotted an infirmary nearby on the way
he reveals to her his weird family past
that he's a half human half vampire
hybrid and he went to go looking for his
missing mother trailing a donation from
his mother to the orphanage and this is
where he met her and the rest of his
friends while talking he kicks this
small rock out of the way and notices
that it slips through this small pink
Vortex meanwhile back on land Mr
detective guy from earlier Trails me
Liu's disappearance and discovers that
all the missing persons were death row
inmates all with messed up bodies that
no autopsy could be found he's denied
access to me Liu's file because of his
high-profile dad but finds out through
his friends that they went to the same
orphanage growing up heading there he
discovers that this was an orphanage for
blood of oars only and finds a box of
toys lying here for some donors and asks
this receptionist for the names of all
the donors to the orphanage he spots one
of the donation toys and finds an
audiobook in it taking it back to his
office he finds audio on it from me Liu
and his friends through this he
discovers that their orphanage was on
the verge of being sold for their land
the real estate agency responsible for
this sale was affiliated with a bank in
town that contained the deed and deposit
for the orphanage itself and this is why
miliu tried to rob that bank to protect
the orphanage and this stuns Mr
detective back on the island of aori Mi
Liu continues to try and get Angie to
the infirmary but starts tripping balls
and hearing voices but suddenly they get
cornered and attacked by some more
flesh-eating monsters and they managed
to pin down me Liu he hopelessly watches
anji get picked up by this monster
before passing out later he wakes up in
his bed in an abandoned Diner noticing
this blonde girl but she just makes
weird sounds and runs away exploring the
area he discovers that me Liu is safe
thanks to Chen Fong and Lee They rescued
them Chen Fong then punches me Liu Hart
and scolds him perhaps telling him that
he was a hemomancer and for not
protecting anji better because uh his
sword has a crush on her but that's not
important Chen Fong tells him that while
they were tracking him and anji they ran
into this blonde girl who doesn't talk
he also says that he wants to go and
save winchao Lee then asks me Liu what
happened to the brunette batty Cho from
earlier but me Liu stares into the
distance not caring one bit later
everyone discovers anji magically all
healed up and she says that a strange
blonde girl was on top of her when she
woke up and then introduced blood of ore
blonde girl and say that they found her
when they were tracking me Liu they
found her in a strange room that looked
like it was shedding its skin and any
liquid from it they touched instantly
melted their objects the whole room
suddenly started melting so they tried
to pick up blonde girl but Lee has a
fear of women so Chen Fong had to be the
one to pick her up that important but
it's a little weird Mei Liu wonders how
Angie came back to life and thinks that
this blonde girl could be connected to
whatever is going on in that room he
tells everyone that they need to head
back to that room to figure out what's
going on and notices Lee taking a bite
out of his knife for no reason but me
Liu pays it to no notice equipping
himself with walkie-talkies so he and
Chen Fong head off leaving Lee to watch
the girls while he sweats buckets
because he's scared of women on the way
they come across some prisoners with
guns and think they must be Lou Yao's
followers looking for weapons suddenly
me Leo's walkie-talkie starts blasting
alerting the bad guy prisoners and
reports that she just noticed that
blonde girls collar counters down to
five meaning she'll soon die unless she
kills something she begs them to come
back so they can figure this out first
this gives me Liu a crazy new idea and
he tells Chen Fong that they'll search
for the melting room later the bad guy
prisoners try and surprise them but
immediately who tricks them and holds
them up at gunpoint forcing him to take
them to Lu Yao how however on the way
there one of the prisoners suddenly gets
eaten by this worm in this building and
the others run for their life it tries
to attack Chen Fong but they realize
that it can't leave this building the
two boys then hear a gunshot nearby and
come across ooyao's men trying to take
down this horrifying werewolf and even
run into win Chow milio quickly saves
him and uses his powers to stop this
werewolf shocking Wing Chao as he
realizes that needle you is a hemomancer
the werewolf transforms back into a kid
and the prisoners tell me Liu that he
just suddenly started going crazy and
transformed and they don't know what
happened this prisoner tells them that
before the kid turned he was holding on
to a red small doll-shaped rock but it
melted away Chen Fong is shocked and
remembers that him and Lee both saw a
red adult too but Emilio knows what this
means and tells him to shut up Emilio
asks to be taken to Liu Yao and win Chow
reluctantly agrees and they head off on
the way Chen Fong Whispers to me Liu
that him and Lee both actually touched
the Redstone they found earlier by but
nothing happened and milieu realizes
that those bloodstones are the key to
Awakening their hemomancy powers and
realize that once everyone's powers on
this island are awakened Humanity will
be thrown into utter chaos they decide
to speed up negotiations with lu Yao and
head back ASAP praying that Lee is still
normal but that was their biggest
mistake to hope they reached Liu Yao's
door but catch him in the middle of a
boo-boo tying with brunette batty Cho
from earlier she's still alive milio
tries to play it cool and finds out from
Lu Yao that he knows Lee miliu tells him
that he was acting weird before they
left and bit off a piece of his knife
before they left Lu Yao tells him that
that must mean that his powers are
Awakening and he will soon turn into a
monster but he notices me Leo wants to
ask something else he tells him that
they want to borrow some weapons but
yalu asks brunette batty Cho if they're
telling the truth it's rather strange
and melee realizes that she must have
some Powers too forced to Spill the
Beans meleu tells them that they want
weapons to help save blonde Girl by
helping her kill a monster to raise up
her collar counter and she might be the
key to solving the mystery behind why
everyone is here on this island lugao
then reveals a stash of weapons and
tells him that he was going to use these
to take down me tenju AKA Melius Daddy
not even realizing that he's standing in
front of the man's very own son okay so
what's going on here right now they've
just figured out that not only is Lou
Yao the most powerful dude here but this
chick that they screwed over rightfully
so now has powers if I was male you I
would first worry about brunette Cho
since her powers could have ended up
screwing us over if she finds out that
we're the son of the guy that Lu Yao
wants to kill but enough of that
brunette Joe taking a moment to see if
what we were thinking was true means
that she likely has the power to
visually see what we think about in the
moment or possibly whether we tell the
truth or not and this means fortunately
there are limitations to her powers
which we could exploit in order to not
get caught so you know what I would do I
would scare her out of my mind Lu Yao
tells him borrowing these guns means
it's gonna cost him he asks me Leo what
his powers are but the kid tries to not
reveal too much he is then led to the
back of the room and LU Yao shows him a
secret that he's never seen before it's
the Island's barrier Lu Yao tells him
that it's this barrier that is keeping
the prisoners inside of this island
until they take it down no one will ever
leave this place he asks me Liu to join
his team but the kid declines so Lu Yao
tries to kill him but suddenly Mei Liu
reveals his powers to save himself
throwing a smoke bomb to cover his
tracks as him and Chen Fong get the hell
out of there and head back to save Lee
flying past winchao he notices that they
dropped one of their walkie-talkies and
hears Angie's Voice through it calling
for help back in the city taking a quick
smoke break his assistant out of nowhere
gets killed and Mr detective is forced
to take cover killing these two men who
try to stop him searching them he finds
out that they work for the BST Emilio's
Daddy's company meanwhile me Leo and
Chen Fung barely escape with their lives
he tells Chen Fong that brunette chill
might now have mind reading powers so
they can't trust her changing plans they
focus on helping blonde girl kill a
monster and head back to meet her and
anji not realizing that it's already too
late nearby Lee has already gone crazy
and his powers have made him very very
strong and he tries to kill blonde girl
and Angie finally cornering them he
attacks but suddenly neelio arrives and
tries to stop him Chen Fong leads the
girls away while Lee begins chasing me
Liu down about to die Emilio yells out
for the monster worm and it attacks Lee
it tries to drag him back inside but
this guy's Powers mutate even more and
he easily drags the worm out and kills
it but then an even bigger monster comes
out and milieu realizes that he needs to
stop this new monster from leaving the
building or else it'll ruin his plans to
save blonde girl Lee tries to fight the
monster but Emilio stops him again just
enough for the monster to lose interest
and go back inside pissed off Lee
prepares to kill me Leo but gets
distracted by Angie he charges at her
but she gets saved by and then blonde
girl nearby gets an idea and me Liu uses
the last of his strength to make Lee
chase him up this building and just then
anji throws this grenade but misses and
it's about to hit me Liu when suddenly
anji's hemomans her powers awaken and
she uses them to push the grenade
towards Lee causing him to get blown up
Anja runs towards a passed out meat Liu
but Lee Rises Up From the Ashes and
heads towards her she gets super mad and
tries to kill him but is stopped by Chen
Fong who tells her that just like the
wolf kid from earlier his Rampage is
over and he'll soon go back to normal
now awake though me Liu tells everyone
that they need to carry out their plan
to help a blonde girl kill a monster and
he says that he's gonna set up
explosives within this building from
earlier and using blonde girl to pull
the trigger miliu then heads inside of
this building and effectively sets up
the bombs one by one but comes across
this room and discovers a piece of
jewelry on this table from his past
remembering that his mother's Assistant
gave this to him he continues searching
this desk and finds a journal document
the research that went on this island
the experiments weren't going well and
so these mad scientists moved on to plan
B and me Liu sadly has an idea and opens
up the computer on his wrist again
finding out more information about Plan
B discovering that anji was one of the
kids they experimented on and that his
parents and their company was a major
part of all of this but out of nowhere a
monster attacks him forcing him to cut
the and finish his bomb job more
monsters start overwhelming him but anji
then shows up and uses her new Shadow
powers to save me Liu allowing them to
escape and he passes out due to the
exhaustion while blonde girl finally
pulls the trigger killing off all of
these monsters and having her neck
counter not explode for a few more days
windchild then shows up out of nowhere
and points a gun at Angie telling her
that he saw her powers emerging on that
day of the bank heist this is why her
collar turned red he blames her for the
deaths of everyone in the bank but their
chat is cut rather short when more
portals open up around them unleashing
hundreds more monsters Lee saves an
unconscious meal Liu and gets his arm
torn off right as Lou Yao's crew also
shows up to save everyone Lee then tries
to use the last of his powers to save
meat Liu but is stopped by Lou Yao
telling him that he'll die if he uses up
all of his powers seeing this anji tries
to stop him right as this terrifying
monster shows up but Lu Yao breaks free
from her powers and manages to kill this
monster and then blonde girl magically
saves me Liu somehow because somehow she
manages to do that and he wakes up and
sees his mother's assistant walk out
from this Monster's corpse leaving
everyone including us with way more
questions than answers but what do you
guys think about it let us know what you
like about it and what you didn't like
about it don't forget to like subscribe
leave a thumbs up leave a comment down
below and as always don't forget to
check out our how to be playlist